I called the king myself this morning to
tell him what the situation here is and
based on common sense and friendship we
decided what the best course of action
would be what would have really not been
feasible for neither the British nor for
us would have been to have tried to
carry on as if nothing was happening
despite what the actual situation is so
we will reorganize this for when calm
returns and we suggested that come the
beginning of Summer and with our Diaries
allowing we will announce details of a
new state visit which will allow us to
properly welcome the new king and the
queen consort and to do this in
conditions that will allow us to show
off France in both Paris and Bordeaux